more than three weeks before Christmas
American Airlines faces a holiday
meltdown a union blames a computer
glitch for giving too many pilots time
off that scheduling mistake could leave
15,000 upcoming flights without a
captain copilot or both and those jets
cannot leave without them Kris Van
Cleave is at the American counter at
Reagan National Airport outside
Washington with the frustration that's
taking off Chris good morning good
morning this software issue could affect
flights between December 17th and the
31st and American is the world's largest
airline so this could have ripple
effects across the country but
particularly in hub cities like New York
Chicago Miami and here in Washington
American says they are working to solve
this problem the pilots union says that
might not be so easy
thousands of holiday travelers are
hoping for a Christmas miracle after the
union representing American Airlines
fifteen thousand pilots warned a looming
pilot shortage could ground flights
around the country it's super stressful
I mean when your flight plans don't work
out you're kind of left stranded it's
not fair and who's gonna fly us home
into our families you know Henry Hart a
belt is an airline analyst this was a
terrible screw-up by American Airlines
it was a programming mistake pilots
normally bid for flight assignments
every month the computer glitch allowed
them to drop their scheduled flights
during the holidays without confirming
another pilot was available as a result
thousands of flights were left unstaffed
American declined to go on camera saying
in a statement we have reserved pilots
to help cover and we are paying pilots
who pick up certain open trips 150
percent of their hourly rate obviously
American does not want to be the airline
equivalent of Scrooge and canceled a lot
of people's vacations still the pilots
union has lodged a protest against the
airline's proposed fix saying it's terms
violate the current labor contract
captain Dennis pagers it's gonna require
some unique thinking and some unusual
arrangements perhaps but none of that
can happen until we are actually able to
sit down and talk about it now American
says it does not intend to cancel any
flights during the holidays and believes
it can fill this pilot void in the
coming days airline analysts say passing
it is not time to panic just yet but
they can't rule out the possibility of
at least some cancellations so Nora will
be watching this closely just a small
panic going on if you have an American
ticket thank you Chris